the base level was just that she wasn't
good enough and like unloved and so that
was just like
[Music]
hi i'm pablo lahren
hey i'm kristen stewart and we are going
to break down a new scene from our movie
spencer
[Music]
yesterday
you arrived after the queen
i got lost well it's a very important
scene for sure because it's it's uh the
movie has is told in three days
and it's the beginning of the second day
and it's actually the only
real face-to-face interaction that diana
has with charles in the movie
and it was uh
nearly eight or nine pages long
a lot of dialogue
and it's it happens at a point where
what i think is very beautiful is that
they don't they they're not really
talking
what is actually happened
and they're just going sideways to to
the heart of the problem which it's a
breakup scene
um but they talk about something else we
keep trying to sort of get the upper
hand on each other and by changing the
subject um and then he ultimately i mean
and maybe this is just my perspective
but um he does he gets the upper hand
and and i start answering these
questions whereas she comes in going i'm
just going to make statements i'm just
going to make statements
so yeah
could you get lost you've lived over the
hill for years
it looks different now
everything looks different
it's a three-tone
huge snooker table it's very english and
and we couldn't find one in germany when
we shot it so we brought one from
england
and snooka tables are usually green and
i
with guy hendrix our production designer
we wanted to have it red which is one of
the main colors not the main color of
the movie
so it was it was not easy to to do it
but it's very symbolic as well and also
because of the positions of the balls
they're in the table
and because of the physicality of the
room
having
each of them on one side of the tool
felt like a game
and at the same time like a battle it
creates a
huge amount of distance they're really
far from each other and you can feel
that
you sure you went late yesterday because
you were delayed by someone
it's a library it's inside of a castle
that today
it's a hotel
and what we did is that we just did some
work in it but it's an original building
that is actually in germany so i don't
think it's actually
not even similar to the one that is in
sunnygram
do you think i got delayed by someone oh
come on come on
it was written like that every beat
of the those guns were in the script and
we just had someone on on the
on the set doing this and christine was
reacting to that
they are circling us didn't you know
don't you read
it seems the circling just me
not you
just me
i'm so interested in
actors that really bare themselves and
feel
entirely themselves all the time and
can't hide in in roles i'm convinced by
actors that really just want to be like
present in every moment and um i've i've
heard
other
actors kind of present the idea of
playing two people or just having a sort
of protective wall of character that you
bring to interviews or a public persona
i just think that that's like literally
the opposite of what i'm trying to do so
i don't want to get closer to i've i
want to become closer
to my work and other people and all of
that and so like absolutely not i think
that that was all something that diana
struggled with as well is that she
wanted and craved proximity and honesty
and emotional connection and she was
sort of begged not to ever do that and
you know to perpetuate a lie and uphold
an ideal that you kind of see through is
painful
it's like uh you know you can't live
your whole life like that we only know
we have one shot at this for sure it's
like to spend your whole life living a
lie it's just something that i don't
know
i don't know how anyone does that the
thing is diana there has to be two of
you
there's there's two of me there's two
father two of everyone
it's the real one
and the one they
take pictures of
you have to be able to make your
body do things
you hate
that you hate
he says there's you have to be two of
you and then he says that
one of those two
has to do things that your body hates
and that's where the scene really is and
and i love what you do after
when you say that you hate that
how you sort of absorbed the the impact
of of that idea
it's very very interesting and i think
it's also calling him out because he
says you have to do things you have to
you have he's trying to help her you
have to make your body do things
that you hate i'm like that you hate why
don't you just say the truth and tell me
you hate me
like just say it
and it's also it's also your son outside
shooting a gun that you think that he
hates that yeah so it's it's related to
is related to doing things that you
don't want to do and you are just
trapped in the wheel of history and
tradition so you're never yourself
you're always someone else and that is a
very interesting and complicated
conflict i think
yes
for the good of the country
the country
yes the people
because they don't want us to be people
it was day three
oh yeah because jack was like only just
gotten it yeah day one
it was more physical
day two is the entrance of the house
yeah with with steam yeah
and then day three was this massive
scene
and we shot it in one day
and we covered it a lot and we just used
the white
lenses on each so it's far more more
cold and at the same time more
more in his perspective but it was it
wasn't the beginning of the shooting it
was not easy yeah somebody asked me the
other day what the first um what the
first day was like and when did you feel
like you really got into her and you
felt
like she was something you understood
physically emotionally that you could
wear her
and uh
it's the the first scene with tim and i
really broke me in
completely
because the first day we had no dialogue
and we just inhabited the space and kind
of walked around and and did some
wordless stuff and
second day was with the kids with tim
it was like in a very large space it was
not intimate it was a it was a
performance it was very much from the
outside
and then
i don't remember that uh scene between
charles and i
being something that felt daunting i was
so in that could have been halfway
through the movie i felt like we were
halfway through the movie i had also
been running that scene with my dialect
coach for months
yeah so yeah
i'm sorry
[Music]
i didn't think about this when we were
there but it's like he's saying will you
please just play the game it's easy if
you just play the game just do the lie
just just go with it and it's she drops
the ball yeah i know it follows the
rules yeah you know where the dress is
in the order that is reaching it almost
feels like a pleading as well you have i
feel bad for him in that scene a lot i
mean you know jack who play jack
freithing who who plays charles did it
in a way that was incredibly human and
and and to me like inviting in in a kind
of ironic way
[Music]
there are certain times where i know
exactly what a scene is about and what
it's trying to say and then there are
times where you sort of
where it kind of changes um i think from
my perspective right now having done the
scene a million times watched it come
together
had some time between myself and the
experience of actually doing it i think
when i turned and dropped the ball
they charles and diana did
miss each other a lot
i know that that sounds how would i know
that
it just energetically that seems like
they both tried in different times to
sort of close the distance between them
and that is speculative and maybe
hopeful on my end and i you know i love
her as a sort of figure and as a person
that i've oddly become spookily close to
so i felt like it was almost like just
as his back is turned she she offers the
thing back you know what i mean but
there's just no there's no way to play
this game we can't play this together
but it's not for lack of trying or
wanting um if if they were compatible
and meant for each other that would have
been really convenient and fun for them
they just weren't um and that was really
forever painful for her that rejection
is simple as that is and and as
complicated as her life is and and how
involved her sort of pain is in in many
different aspects
the base level was just that she wasn't
good enough and like unloved and so that
was just like
i guess we should stop trying and i
think it's the gesture yeah i'm trying
how you drop it it's like it's just it
because i i wouldn't i would have given
you everything yeah
but that's what i mean it's a breakup
scene
and that ball kind of
is you know it just shows and symbolize
that game's over that's it yeah fight
them
you are your own weapon
[Music]
check out our movie spencer in theaters
now
you